[Musique]
bonjour à tous et bienvenue dans ce
nouveau numéro du 7-8 culture
aujourd'hui nous sommes au château de
breteuil à choisel de nouvelles scènes
de comptes sont ouverts aux visiteurs
dans les dépendances du château voici le
sommaire des nouveautés au château de
breteuil de nouvelles scènes de comptes
viennent d'ouvrir leurs portes aux
visiteurs peau d'âne et le petit poucet
plusieurs mois de travaux pour une
scénographie en son et lumière une
exposition sur le marché de poissy est
visible à la maison de faire de la ville
à l'occasion des 200 ans de la halle on
y découvre l'un des plus grands marchés
aux bestiaux de paris au xixème siècle
et enfin le mois molière dévoile sa
nouvelle programmation 26e édition en
juin à versailles créateur de cet
événement le maire de la ville nous en
parle
[Musique]
on
où
je me trouve dans le salon empire du
château de breteuil à choisel les scènes
de deux comptes en son et lumière sont à
présent l'adn du château depuis 1980 la
belle au bois dormant ou encore le petit
chaperon rouge des contes de charles
perrault prennent place dans les
dépendances du château jean emmanuel le
char au bonjour bonjour vous êtes
l'administrateur du château vous
proposer cette année deux nouveautés de
nouvelles scénographies le petit poucet
dans le four à pain et peau d'âne dans
l'ancien lavoir pourquoi avoir pris ces
deux contrats en particulier il ya déjà
il faut redonner vie à ces lieux
d'autrefois donc peau d'âne était dans
le lavoir depuis plusieurs années mais
elles étaient devenues désuètes il
fallait moderniser peau d'âne et puis
utiliser toute la technologie moderne
plaît beaucoup à notre jeune public donc
ça a été la première rénovation
et puis le petit poucet dans le four à
pain là ça a été une réelle création il
y avait un ancien petit poucet qui était
dans un tout autre endroit et qui était
difficile d'accès dont nous avons
entièrement créé le petit poucet
actuelle avec encore plus de technologie
d'ailleurs que pour peau d'âne j'imagine
que c'est un gros chantier quand même
deux nouvelles scénographies dans votre
château oui tout à fait alors chaque
nouvelle scène de comptes représentent
plusieurs mois de travail pour
différents corps de métier il ya
beaucoup de technologies modernes qui
est maintenant utilisé pour plaire au
jeune public et justement est-ce que le
château de bretagne mise sur ses scènes
de compte pour peut-être attirer des
familles mais bien sûr ce que c'est sans
arrêt se renouveler nous avons beaucoup
de familles très fidèles qui viennent
deux fois par an à breteuil par exemple
c'est important pour que ces familles
quand elles reviennent découvre des
nouveautés alors les jardins change bien
sûr avec les saisons mais les scènes de
comptes doivent aussi au fil des années
se moderniser alors je vous propose que
l'on découvre ces deux nouvelles scènes
et comment elles ont été réalisées alors
attention l'ogre dort profondément
dans les dépendances du château de
breteuil une toute nouvelle scénographie
est à découvrir dans l'ancien four à
pain le conte du petit poucet de charles
perrault il y racontait un travail de
six mois pour le scénographe
[Musique]
dans cette scène il y a plein de
particularités déjà vous avez trois
vidéos projections qui se répondent vous
avez d'abord le visage de charles
perrault qui parlent directement au
public donc là on a imprimé le visage
d'un comédien ont l'impression 3d vous
avez aussi des images aériennes un film
et avec un drone vous avez aussi au
niveau des particularités un ogre qui
est immense qui fait trois mètres de
haut et cet ordre est bien du coup il
est créé sur mesure pour la scène du
château de breteuil donc un visage en
silicone démence illico les bottes qu'on
a réalisé en interne au château de
bretagne qui font un mètre vingt deux
auteurs qui sont en plâtre et puis dans
le décor beaucoup de détails parce que
tout le souci du détail est important
les spectateurs vont suivre les
aventures du petit poucet incarné par un
comédien
on a ouvert un casting au grand public
donc on a eu 36 petit poucet qui se sont
présentés et on a choisi un yvelinois un
rambolitains précisément qui s'appelle
donovan le bourhis qui avait sept ans au
moment du tournage il lui manquait sa
tente devant et puis surtout il avait
beaucoup d'espoir et glory beaucoup de
naturel une autre scène de compte a été
rénové peau d'âne dans l'ancien la voir
vraiment soucieux comme moi cachée sous
cette poule donne a dû conquérir legarda
prince
a laissé moi goûter mon histoire on est
plutôt dans une scène qui a été recréée
repensé et modernisé
l'idée c'est que toute la scénographie
s'articule autour d'un court métrage qui
s'intègre vraiment dans le décor de cet
ancien lavoir avec des accessoires
d'antan et la fameuse peau d'âne un
coffre magique et les fameuses robes
robes couleur du temps de l'une et de
soleil d'une durée de 5 minutes la
scénographie de peau d'âne a demandé
deux mois de travail pour découvrir ces
deux nouvelles scènes de compte le
château de breteuil est ouvert tous les
jours y compris le 1er et le 8 mai
jean-emmanuel charolais visiteurs se
posent parfois la question du choix de
charles perrault pour cm puisque cela
pourrait être aussi en d'autres
écrivains alors pourquoi lui alors
pourquoi lui bien tout simplement parce
que charles perrault au tout début de sa
carrière quand il était jeune a commencé
sa carrière auprès de louise breteuil
notre ancêtre qui était ministre des
finances au tout début du règne de louis
xiv alors charles perrault avait
travaillé au service des impôts bien
avant d'entrer en littérature
ce qu'il a fait par la suite il a été
membre de l'académie française il a
écrit les contes de perrault à l'âge de
63 ans mais sa carrière vraiment il
avait commencé en tant qu avocat
fiscaliste sous les ordres directs du
ministre des finances louis de breteuil
donc on rend hommage maintenant à cette
amitié cette collaboration de travail
entre les deux hommes alors on va parler
à présent de la programmation à venir au
château de breteuil les samedi 30 avril
vous présenterez un parcours spectacle
dans le château aux visiteurs c'est ça
oui alors cette visite théâtralisée se
situera essentiellement au
rez-de-chaussée dans des salons qui sont
habituellement fermée aux visiteurs
c'est vraiment une immersion dans
l'époque 1900 qui est proposé aux
visiteurs ils vont se mêler au personnel
du château la femme de chambre qui
raconte un peu sa vie son métier la
gouvernante le majordome qui va
expliquer comment on plaçait les gens à
table les arts de la table
là le pâtissier et sa femme monsieur
même macarons dans les cuisines vont
également montré comment ce que l'on
travaillait avec toute une brigade dans
les cuisines à la belle époque et puis
pouvoir est le grand couturier parlera
de la mode les robes qu'il crée pour les
grandes dames de l'époque et puis parmi
ces dames célèbre il ya réjane réjane
qui fera partie effectivement les
comédiens ainsi pour parler aux
visiteurs de la musique du chant de
l'époque et puis le clou de la visite
c'est le marquis et la marquise de
breteuil qui à la fin du parcours et
bien accueille les visiteurs comme s'ils
accueillaient leurs propres invités et
leur font danser une petite danse de
l'époque et blanc et en mai il y aura
aussi deux rendez vous à ne pas manquer
le dimanche 22 mai et le 26 mai si je me
trompe pas oui alors le 22 mai
effectivement là ce sont les costumes
traditionnels régionaux qui vont venir
défiler c'est la troisième année ce1
beaucoup de succès il y aura environ 25
couples qui vont défiler alors il y aura
plusieurs défilés dans l'après midi puis
de toute façon ils se promènent dans les
jardins dans toutes les dépendances
toute la journée il peut y avoir un
couple d'alsaciens qui peut croiser un
couple de basques de portugais ou ou de
croates voilà donc différentes
nationalités ou régions de france sont
représentées avec des costumes
traditionnels régionaux très bien et le
26 mai sur m6 mais c'est l'escrimé
artistique voilà les lames sur seine une
association d'escrimé artistique vient
au bord du miroir d'eau dans l'est dans
les jardins faire une démonstration des
scream c'est un peu un spectacle de cape
et d'épée qui plaît tous les enfants
garçons fille et puis les parents aussi
très bien s'est dotée on sera là au
rendez vous merci beaucoup jean rené
char ou d'avoir durant l'été merci
à à
l'occasion de la naissance de la halle
du marché de poissy il ya 200 ans
l'exposition bestiaux la foire est
visible à la maison de fer à poissy elle
retrace l'évolution de ce lieu et de la
place de la république plaque tournante
du commerce de bestiaux au 19e siècle
au plus fort de l'activité on arrive
jusqu'à douze mille têtes de bétail qui
était présente ici des boeufs des
moutons et des dévots essentiellement il
faut imaginer il y a deux cents ans sur
l'actuelle place de la république à côté
de l'hôtel de ville à poissy l'un des
principaux marchés aux bestiaux de paris
à l'occasion de l'exposition et des 200
ans de la halle du marché nous avons
fait installer des bâches qui reprennent
les principales oeuvres artistiques qui
sont présentés dans l'exposition
puisqu'un peu plus loin la maison de
faire de poissy bestiaux la foire
retrace l'évolution du marché aux
bestiaux de la commune le marché un
marché ait connu depuis mille ans à peu
près à tester depuis mille ans qui
s'appelait la foire à l'époque mais
c'est sous sa loïc en fait
l'autorisation a été donnée par le roi
de commerce des têtes de bétail donc on
peut parler de 800 ans de marché aux
bestiaux sur la ville de poissy après
l'ouverture de la halle en 1822 le
marché va tripler il va atteindre sa
taille maximale en 1867 avec 2,5 ha fois
ci se trouve en fait à
à la jonction en fait plusieurs voies
routières se situe le long de la seine à
un positionnement géographique
particulièrement intéressant car il ya
un pont qui enjambe d'une des premières
maisons de la région parisienne et en
fait été beaucoup plus facile pour ceux
qui arrivaient par voie navigable de
s'arrêter impossible au port de poissy
et de traversée par la route toutes les
méandres qui mène au coeur de la ville
de paris dans cette exposition des
tableaux des dessins caricatures mais
aussi des plans d'archivés municipales
sont présentés l'occasion de valoriser
le patrimoine l'histoire de la ville et
sa toponymie cette carte qui il a
d'abord la révolution quelle occasion de
voir comment tous les troupeaux arrivait
en fait par toutes les portes de la
ville
donc cette porte de paris existe encore
une part l'apport de la tournelle ici on
a le pont qui traverse la scène à partir
de 1844 un concours de boeufs gras est
organisée il sera à l'origine du salon
de l'agriculture inauguré en 1964
l'exposition est visible jusqu'au 6
novembre dans les yvelines des festivals
sont à prévoir dans vos agendas les
prochaines semaines on commence avec les
vadrouille théâtrale premier festival de
théâtre pour la ville de plaisir du 12
au 15 mai le théâtre coluche la clé des
champs et le conservatoire de la commune
se sont associés pour proposer une
programmation sur le thème de la
transmission à bougival le festival au
cours maintenant revient pour une
cinquième édition du 10 au 24 mai deux
jeunes réalisateurs viennent présenter
leur court métrage au théâtre du grenier
de prix seront attribués et à la fin de
chaque projection les spectateurs
peuvent échanger avec les réalisateurs
[Musique]
comme tous les mois de juin à versailles
le mois molière record pour une 26e e
édition un mois consacré au théâtre et à
la musique
de nombreuses compagnies viendront
présenter leurs créations aux
spectateurs on en parle avec françois de
mazières le maire de versailles moi oui
il est très diversifié avec des scènes
de création mais aussi des reprises et
on sait que la marque de tomber de ce
festival c'est d'être dans tous les
quartiers il ya soixante huit
représentations il ya notre cour
d'honneur comme un avignon c'est le lieu
principal un peu mythique est bien pour
nous c'est les grandes écuries du
château de versailles c'est là où il ya
une programmation va dire un peu
officielle autour aussi beaucoup de
spectacles de musique bref un grand
classique et c'est la fin de 7,8 culture
merci de nous avoir suivis rendez vous
la semaine prochaine dans un autre lieu
culturel évinois bonne soirée sur tsa
oh
[Musique]